hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the magnus carlton invitational we
are
uh in the match for the third place
while geary is brawling it out with
danny pommy she
the game between magnus scotland and
wesley so the first game ended extremely
abruptly and i decided to show it
immediately
as it's uh quite quite to the miniature
so without further ado and without
spoiling anything
let's check out what happens here so
magnus with the white pieces opens with
e4 uh we have e5 by wesley knight to f3
and knight to f6 wesley goes for the
uh petrov defense with knight to c3
that's not a knight tonight the c3 and
knight the c6 and now
uh there are so many moves you can play
here a lot of moves are very very
very popular but the move magnus plays
a4
is not a new move but it has only been
played a handful of times
uh so here bishop to b4 uh the
continuing development preparing the
castle
and magnus goes for bishop to d3 now
bishop captures
knight will not be uh doing anything
because the e4 pawn uh is defended here
so here we have d6 by magnus and it is
uh
sorry by wesley and it is uh only as of
move five that we have a completely new
game
uh instead of d6 castling is a new move
here but d6 uh
uh a new move so now uh let's see how
magnus proceeds here so this is only
move five already a completely new game
uh both players castle we have castles
castles in the now
knight to d5 and not the d knight the d5
is a very sneaky idea
uh because if you go after the knight
knight captures on e5 and e captures
then the bishop is trapped the knight
has to move and once you move the knight
you simply attack the bishop b4 bishop
b6 and a5
and you trap this bishop so instead
after this knight to d5 wesley went for
bishop to c5 right away
but now comes c3 preparing the exact
same idea
not that obviously uh b4 and a5 and now
comes
a5 so stopping b4 uh we have bishop back
to c2 now making room for the d-pawn
and now comes knight captures on d5 with
e captures on the e5
and the knight to e7 now going after the
d5 pawn
and magnus take this opportunity as the
g5 pawn is no longer covered to go for
knight to g5 now putting pressure on h7
and the wesley needs to defend this and
he does it by playing h6
he tries to chase back the knight but
now we have d4 by magnus
attacking the bishop and also offering
this trade if
pawn captures knight pawn captures
bishop then black's king
side the structure is a bit ruined ideas
like queen h5 are already possible
bishop captures and g5 are coming
and you didn't really gain anything by
doing this so instead after this d4 move
uh we have bishop back to b6 by wesley
and
now comes knight the h7 attacking the
rook here
and if you don't want to lose the
exchange you have to play rook to e8
rook to e8 the only good move for wesley
and now knight the f6 check by magnus so
what do you play here if you don't
capture the knight you're gonna be down
the exchange so here g
captures on f6 and now queen to h5
so again what do you play here well uh
wesley wants to shut down this bishop so
he starts with e4 and e4
is indeed the absolute best move here
the problem is if magnus captures it
then you can play f5 with tempo
and now you don't really have a good
move uh you can either move the bishop
and then the knight comes to g6
everything is nicely defended uh or you
can go for bishop captures and g5 but
then after f captures an e4 queen g5
check you will not
be uh delivering checkmate because
knight to g6 and black is now perfectly
fine
uh of course even winning so instead
after this
e4 move we have rook to e1 now get
putting additional pressure along the e
file and also preparing a nice rook leaf
rook the e3 rook the g3 is coming
so here we have f5 by wesley and f5
is uh uh maybe not
the the most precise way to go about
this uh
instead of f5 you could consider
something like c5 also knight the g6 is
all
is always an idea but f5 does something
uh that you do not want to allow here
and here
uh he allows it magnus goes for bishop
captures on h6
and now already some very uh well
uh sneaky ideas are possible because
if you go knights to g6 now now bishop
to g5
attacking the queen and once the queen
moves now you go bishop to f6
and there's no defense against uh queen
to h6 followed by queen to g7 checkmate
so instead
after this bishop captures an h6 we have
knight captures on the e5 by wesley
but this is not all that much better
bishop to g5
attacking the queen now f6 not much uh
not much better uh to be done here
and now bishop to b3 attacking the the
knight here on d5 and here if you
capture on g5 then
uh queen to g6 check is winning for
white if king to f8 bishop captures on
the 5 threatening checkmate
and if you defend this let's say bishop
to e6 or something
then we have bishop captures and after
rook captures just queen captures
and it's uh okay white uh will not be
able to deliver checkmate but he's up
material he's up uh
uh up the exchange and this dark square
bishop is a pretty bad piece if black
doesn't uh
well get some sort of a counter play
then you can just shift the rook into
the attack and that's just it
the there's no playing this for black so
instead after bishop to b3 we have c6
defending the knight here
and now of course comes rook to e3 again
with the same idea i'm now offering the
rook
uh because if the rook is captured uh
well
it cannot be captured because the the a
knight is pinned
so king the f8 unpinning and now
preparing to win the rook and
now comes queen to g6 a deadly idea here
uh the problem is if you start running
away for example king to e7 you're gonna
get bishop captures on f6 with
check and black loses the queen here
because if you capture the bishop then
queen cap
queen to f7 is checkmate so instead
after queen to g6
uh after instead of king to e7 we have
this
f4 move by wesley but now this also
doesn't work
so feel free to pause the video here and
win the game uh it's actually
mate in three for magnus while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding the
unstoppable mate in three and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
uh
bishop to h6 with check queen to h6 also
wins but this is just much faster
uh and there is nothing more to be done
here king to e7 we have queen to h7 with
check and it was in this position on
move 23
that wesley still resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
whatever you do you're getting
checkmated but there is only one
legal move for black that's king to e6
and then of course
rook captures an e4 will be checkmate so
uh a very
uh crushing defeat uh and a great start
for magnus
to win the third place of the magnus
carlson invitational we'll see what
happens in the
uh in the uh main match uh between
anishigiri and yaniponishi
but i'm now receiving information that
the first game ended in a draw so we'll
see what happens there
uh sir awesome game i hope you guys
enjoyed that
i would like to thank robert goher paula
[ __ ] andrew sabag
norm tremblay and william gould for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
uh continuing the coverage of the magnus
cross and invitational finals checking
up on your wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day